we're at the mercy of the wind in the
town of taylorsville they're preparing
for the fires advance
dan kern is a volunteer firefighter and
this place is his home
right now the wind's expected to do this
if the wind does that titusville is in
trouble taylorsville's in trouble and
genesee is in trouble and like and all
of
all of this is in trouble a five-minute
drive north and this is what they're
facing
this is just one flank of the vast blaze
it covers more than 700 square miles now
beyond this up the valley is greenville
the town already taken
we watch a relay of helicopters with
their buckets they have the most
enormous challenge and the wind is
picking up now the flames burn stronger
this is just what the people of
taylorsville have feared
the town itself is quiet like much of
the area it's under an evacuation order
but a small group have stayed behind
every community here has a fire station
and in taylorsville it's now doubling as
a distribution center thank you very
much
i'll see you later lauren bye-bye bye
as a small community everybody pitches
in and does what they can so i would say
we've only got about a quarter of our
population that's hung in here and
stayed because they're ranchers or
they've got animals and stuff that they
have to tend to so they're not going to
leave
up the road a spot fire has ignited it's
tiny but from this they can grow so fast
it's a lone policeman who tries to put
it out you can see why some in the
community want to stay it's all hands on
here
back in town dan raises an issue we hear
so much here frustration with the idea
that this is all just about climate
change the state of the forest is the
number one
the number one problem um we have
there are factors such as a changing
climate temperatures being different
rainfall amounts being different but
with the state of the forest that they
are in there is literally no
there's no stopping these fires there is
a chasm between local knowledge and what
he says are well-intentioned but
misguided environmentalists
but i'm sick of their ideas they're not
working like when and i would encourage
them to come out and listen to what the
loggers have to say listen to what the
ranchers have to say listen to what the
sheep farmers have to say listen
to what the native americans
have to say
because that is where the solution lies
that is the bigger debate the clash of
ideas but there is an immediate
challenge and it's closing in mark stone
sky news in california